what was your experience of women you
know before you met this uh
Ukrainian lady
did for a few years because I was too
busy traveling around Europe at the time
like for several years I had maybe I was
like two serious relationships before
that but uh nothing
groundbreaking yeah I've always said
that Eastern European women are women on
hard mode a lot of a lot of guys dig
their VI hey look I know you know I fell
for it for quite a few years in my 20s I
dated you know Eastern European women
almost exclusively
um but they are women on hard mode
they're very hot they're attractive
they're sultry but uh they're a handful
too
so you asked me how I couldn't stop this
I mean I physically can't stop her from
leaving she's leaving but I'm at this
point one candidate anyway you can't
right exactly I mean there's nothing on
my hands are tired literally I can't
force her from leaving she said she's
going and so I was basically sitting at
home taking care of the kids and taking
care of her of her mother so along the
way as I mentioned she found one guy
that ultimately fell in love with her
and now we're getting close to the sort
of the separation period now and a few
times a year she would go on these big
four or five hour dinners with this
colleague that also graduate here from
UBC the University of British Columbia
and then in January of 2018 she went to
a conference in PEI
yeah you know where this is going
already right and she spent four or five
days staying at this man's house while
she attended there and then when she
returned from her trip she made the
announcement to me that she was now in a
serious relationship with this professor
at the University of Prince Edward
Island
so that kind of solidified things and
from there things really uh really
started to to escalate and now all along
I kind of felt like like I was objecting
to her going out but also part of me
felt like and I feel kind of I was
stupid to think this but I thought that
she'd never cheat on me because of her
strong Ukrainian morals and in hindsight
I just think it's probably highly
unlikely that she was faithful during
that time and even during the trial when
making sure she wasn't faithful during
much of the marriage the way that you
describe it well
even during the trial when my lawyer was
cross-examining her when the lawyer
mentioned about you know this infidelity
you should have seen how upset she got
on she felt so she reacted so indignant
like how dare you ask me this question
like she really got upset and in fact
that Outburst basically told everyone in
the courtroom that yeah the likelihood
of her being uh faithful was pretty
pretty small did she end up bringing the
Babushka with her over to Pei as well no
she's leaving us all home so she's
leaving us all here in Vancouver to
basically do our thing yeah no sorry so
you're in Vancouver but she's in PEI
right
she just moved September 6th of 2022 so
we're talking just over did she bring
her mother with her too she passed away
she passed away I see okay but the kids
are with her right now the kids are with
her right now and the new boyfriend you
know with the professor
yes they're engaged being married and
that's where they're living right now
okay
um you've got some points here about
some of the stuff that went on during
the breakup as well can you go through
those
yeah sure so um so she announces she's
in this big this new serious
relationship and things really start to
estimate this is mid-January
at this point she's now vocally telling
the children that I am not their father
stop calling me dad stop calling me Papa
he's not your father we're going to get
a new father
she would if we would start playing on
the ground she would like pick him up
and say okay it's time for bedtime come
with me sometimes even hurting them and
I'm taking audio of these situations
because I realize things is really
starting to get out of control uh she's
also excluding me from dinner from food
activities any sort of activities I do
with the family and then on February
23rd you're still living under the same
roof at this time yeah so she's
attempting to alienate you from the kids
even under the same house well I
wouldn't use the word attempting she is
she was feeling dating yeah
uh and on February 23rd this is 2018 uh
she committed domestic violence and so
uh and they're camping uncertainty about
that because I do have it on audio and
on the next day in the February 24th I
went down to the rcmb station
um just the way things worked in Canada
here for our U.S friends I'm on the
endowment lands like University property
and so that's federal land and then
under the jurisdiction of the RCMP or
the Royal Canadian Mounted Police and
not the local Vancouver Police so just
explaining that quickly uh she I went
down to talk with Constable Thompson and
asked him what would happen if I pressed
charges and he basically said if she
gets arrested then she won't be able to
work with children and that was her
whole entire career and so I didn't want
to basically torpedo her entire career
at that moment decided I'm going to deal
with it through the family courts not
through Criminal Court
that was a big mistake
things are escalating getting worse
that's February 23rd on March 7th this
is by this point though like she's
already going out for a long weekends
she's partying she's doing dinners
you're you know she's alienated you from
the kids
um why did you play the nice guy card
I knew from talking with her that she
wasn't going to be negotiating now at
this point we already knew that we were
moving out so it was just a survival
mode at this point just trying to know
but I mean like you had an opportunity
to basically pivot the direction of this
uh untying of the knot in your favor and
you didn't take that like
I mean with divorce look man it's
I'm talking to people watching right now
because it's a little bit too late for
you but it's like look I'm in the woman
you marry is not the woman that you
divorce and in situations like this
where you see the writing on the wall
you have to take any opportunity if ever
shows up and it's rare
you had a good opportunity but I mean
you just played the nice guy card and
just continued on with the you know
let's go through the due process like
why did you do that
felt like I was at I invested so many
years in her education helping her get
through and get a career that if I had
pursued domestic violence charges
against her and had her prosecute had
her arrested that that would undo all
that work I had done and I still exactly
that was the DV issue
on the 23rd yeah when you had to deal
with RCMP for the DV issue slapping on
the face uh hitting in the stomach and
hitting me with uh objects in the
kitchen like physical and you have proof
of that too right like you heard you're
like yes okay yes yes yes that have been
well the cops didn't they when they used
submit anything to like here at least in
BC they told me the process is it gets
submitted they take all the evidence and
then it goes to prosecutor's office and
they decide whether to continue the
investigation or do you have visible
injuries on your body from her
I did I took a couple pictures but I
didn't pursue it at the time
stupidity all right so you let that one
go okay yeah uh and then on March 7th uh
2018 so we're talking just a couple
weeks later uh again there was a an
altercation where she was
um
and I had the whole thing on the on
audio like from start until finish it
was only seven minutes long and she
basically
escalates super fast she starts hitting
me she's punching me she's kicking me
and eventually it ends with me calling
uh 9-1-1 that's an audio cuts off and so
I did call the rcnp they did come uh to
the house and they obviously the police
come in right they're separating
everybody they take me downstairs they
leave her up here upstairs with the in
our home with the children take
different statements and then the police
came back and said well she said a
different statement than you do and I
said well I have the whole thing on
audio it didn't bother to listen to the
audio they just said we need you to
leave and I said well why should I leave
I'm not the person who who assaulted
because they came back she's refusing to
leave I'll put here that you cooperated
if at least you leave for a 24-hour
cooling off period
so I thought okay fine but make sure you
put in there that I cooperate I just
said I just need to grab my my stuff
because I was afraid she was going to
destroy it and I I left that night and I
stayed at a friend's house that night
so
um that night did you have a lawyer at
that time
only on consultant basis so I was
talking to a lawyer but I hadn't
retained a lawyer yet did you get any
feedback from the lawyer about the DV
issues you know because she's obviously
an aggressive person if she's punching
and hitting you all these times right
yeah he told me that the next time she
does it to call the police and have it
stopped okay so you're the one that
initiated the call you're the one that
had the recording and even though you
had the evidence they still made you
leave yes did you get a chance to call
your lawyer that night
um no where you left no okay no I did
not okay
okay so I leave no charges are pressed
that night she runs to the hospital uh
Vancouver General Hospital here in
Center City
and she tells the hospital social
workers that I'm abusing her and later
on and I know this because later on I
got the reports from the hospital and
she specifically said to hold the nurse
and then later on a social worker from
there came to interview her and at that
point that triggers the mcfd which is
the ministry of Family and Child
Development these are social workers
that can take kids away okay so it's
quite a scary thing
so all this is happening and I'm just I
get like I'm staying at my friend's
place and what am I doing I'm
transcribing this audio because I'm
thinking like oh I've got to get back
and I've not get back at her but I mean
I've got to get get this information to
people so they can see it and sure
enough the next morning at like nine
o'clock in the morning get this phone
call and answer you know hello
hi this is the ministry of Family and
Child Development
um we're the social workers here we hear
that you're abusing your wife
I said well actually that's funny you
should say that because I'm just in the
middle of transcribing the audio where
she is physically assaulting me would
you like to hear it
and everything changed that first couple
minutes was extremely uncomfortable
because I kept like this sort of
accusing me of doing this accusing me of
doing that and then suddenly when I told
him I had audio tape and then she was
like can you be at your home today at 3
P.M and I said yes can you bring the
audio with me and they said yes and so
um I showed up that day this is now
March 8th 2018. I show up at the home
she's here and as she's walking in she's
holding up her hand with the little you
know the little bandage thing on Yelling
in front of the children oh you hurt me
you hurt me you broke my hand you broke
my hand
and I'm just quiet and I walk in and the
social workers they come in and then now
complete this is we need to hear the
audio first how does she hurt her hand
from hitting you yeah yeah yeah in fact
the results from the ministry and they
had to do it obviously an investigation
is the results from there in their
report they specifically say the mother
likely injured her hand from assaulting
the husband in other words and you know
how it is like if you do any sort of
martial arts if you don't know what
you're doing and you're not punching
your fingers properly you can easily
hurt a finger especially when she was
you know grabbing my stomach kicking and
punching and even if you are trained you
know your body is still going to react
and try to protect yourself you know
from the face or in the stomach it's
uncontrollable so
um yeah so they dragged me into the room
they want to hear the audio tape and
they're just like that's it we're taking
the kids away you know don't worry
everything's gonna be taken care of and
then they take her in the other room 20
minutes later they come out and say
she's saying something completely
different
well what is it I'm sorry we don't have
enough evidence to take the kids away
and then what my uh ex did is uh she
left that day uh with the children and
there was nothing I could physically do
to stop her from walking out the door
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out